let's do a few more examples of seeing
if either an atom or an entire molecule
is chiral
so here i have a molecule let's see if
we can identify any chiral centers or
any chiral atoms or asymmetric carbons
all words for the same thing although i
guess you could have chiral centers that
aren't necessarily carbon but it tends
to be carbon most of the time especially
in an organic chemistry class
so if we look here the one that kind of
jumps out this carbon right here is
bonded to three hydrogens and another
carbon so this is obviously not going to
be a chiral center it's bonded to three
of the same group
these three guys are all bonded to two
hydrogens each so they're all bonded to
two of the same group so they can't be
chiral centers
this carbon right here is bonded to
three hydrogens once again three of the
same group not going to be a chiral
center this one looks interesting looks
like it could be a good candidate for
chiral center or chiral carbon or an
asymmetric carbon over here on the left
it's bonded to a methyl group
so this is a methyl
group and here on the right it's bonded
to a butyl group
here on the right it is bonded to a
butyl group
it is bonded to a
butyl group over here it's bonded to an
o h and then over here it's bonded to an
h so this is definitely a chiral carbon
we could put a little asterisks here
that's how they often denote that this
is a chiral carbon and if this doesn't
make sense to you because you might say
hey sal look this carbon is bonded to
two other carbons isn't that the same
thing but the point here is that we're
not looking at what atoms it's directly
bonded to we're looking at the groups
that it's bounded to in this case this
hydrogen is a group and an atom over
here it's an entire group it's entire
butyl group we have four carbons here we
only have one over here another way to
think about it we could have drawn this
we could have drawn this molecule like
this we could have had a carbon
in the center and maybe this methyl
group is popping out like this
so maybe this methyl group
is popping out like this you have your
ch3 and then you would have this
hydrogen coming out maybe in the plane
and then behind it you would have the
butyl group
so
kind of the back leg of the tripod you'd
have a butyl what is that that's c4
h9 right that's six plus c4h9 so it's
c4h9
in the back and then above it you have
your oh
above it
in a different color
you have your o-h and when you look at
it like this it looks just like the
other chiral carbons that we had
identified in previous in actually the
last video looks very similar to
something like this
and when you take its mirror image this
and this is the same molecule here i
kind of made it a little bit more
three-dimensional but if you take the
mirror image of either one you're going
to find that no matter how you take how
you try to rotate it or shift it you
won't be able to superimpose it on its
mirror image for the same reasons as the
other ones and i challenge you to if you
can if you can so these so this is a
chiral carbon this is a this is a chiral
chiral
chiral center we could say or we could
even call it a a asymmetric carbon it
could be considered a stereocenter
or a
stereodenicgenic center all of those are
valid things to call this carbon right
there and this is also a chiral molecule
this is also a chiral molecule
chiral
molecule now let's look at this blue
example
right here
and just as if we wanted to name it just
so we get a little bit of review we
could start it this fluorine right there
one two three four five
five this is what this is one comma
three
one comma three difloro
cyclocyclopendane so that was a nice
review of naming but let's think about
whether we have any chiral centers here
and whether the molecule as a whole is
chiral
so
the immediate ones that we can kind of
dismiss and actually let me let me get
rid of this numbering here just because
i don't want you to think that there's
somehow three hydrogens there this is
the number that was the number three
hydrogen number one car number three
carbon number two carbon so on and so
forth but let me get rid of them now
that we've
now that we've named the molecule don't
want to confuse how many hydrogens we
have at any of these points
so let's look at the carbons well we can
immediately dismiss that carbon that
carbon and that carbon because each of
those are bonded to two hydrogens if we
wanted to break it out it would they
would look like
this so they're bonded to carbons
carbons and then they're bonded to
hydrogens now these might be different
groups these might be different types of
alkane groups that it's bonded to so
that doesn't necessarily throw it out of
the running but these two the two
hydrogens that it's bonded to are
definitely the same atom the same group
we have an axis of symmetry through
through
through that atom so it cannot be a
stereogenic center it cannot be an
asymmetric carbon it cannot be a chiral
center or a chiral atom so we can knock
those guys out of the running but this
guy and that guy seem pretty interesting
because if we were to break it out a
little bit
you could
break it out like that and
break it out like that instead of
writing a ch actually show the bond to
the hydrogen and this guy is bonded to
one hydrogen one fluorine and then if we
were to work our way around around the
cycle and the cyclical these these
cyclic molecules are a little bit it's
sometimes a little tricky to identify
whether you're uh whether you're bonded
to
the same group or different groups but
actually let me not make it too messy
while we try to figure this out to
figure out whether it's bonded to the
same group let's kind of take a walk
around the the cycle around the the
cyclopentane ring
if we go this way if we go on a counter
we do a different color
if we go in a counterclockwise direction
from the carbon in question we're going
to hit a ch2
then we're going to hit a ch so we're
going to hit a ch2 then we're going to
hit a ch if we go this way
we're going to hit a ch2 and then we're
going to hit another ch2 so this guy is
fundamentally whether this bond is
bonded to a different group then that
bond up there is and it's also bonded to
a hydrogen also bonded to a fluorine so
this is bonded to four different groups
so this is a chiral carbon
so that is a chiral center
chiral center now the exact same
argument can be made for this carbon
right here you can make that exact same
argument that look if you were to walk
if you were to walk counterclockwise
from this or if you were right counter
clockwise you would hit a ch2 then a ch2
if you were to go clockwise you just ch2
then a ch which happens to be connected
to a fluorine so you're actually going
to see something you're actually going
to see something different depending
whether you're going down that into that
group or into that group and then it's
also bonded to a hydrogen and a fluorine
four different groups this is also a
chiral center another way to think about
it and it's actually interesting to
compare it
to this molecule up here which was not
chiral and did not have a chiral center
this molecule up here and let me draw a
little different to make it a little bit
more clear
let me draw it a little bit different
so this one i could draw it like
i can draw it like this
i'm just making
if you have the chlorine like that over
here we thought about this as a
potential chiral center and it's kind of
playing the same role as in that example
down here
as in this example of this carbon down
here but you see over here
this is not a chiral center because
there's actually an axis axis of
symmetry for this molecule that goes
through that carbon so you can actually
just draw an axis of symmetry
that goes exactly through that carbon
it's not you know the way i drew it it's
not completely neat but you can see that
that is the reflection of that if i were
to draw the bonds actually a little bit
more symmetric over here if we try to do
the exact same thing if we try to draw
an axis of symmetry over here
we try it on axis we can make that bond
to the fluorine go through our axis of
symmetry we'll see that that still is
not this is still not the reflection of
this because we have a fluorine up here
we don't have a fluorine over here and
we could do the same thing with this end
if you try to do an axis of symmetry
fluorine up there no fluorine over here
so this each of these are definitely
chiral centers while this carbon up here
this carbon up here was not a chiral
center now
the next question is well this thing's
got two chiral centers two chiral
carbons it's probably a car a chiral
molecule everything else we've seen so
far if you've had a chiral center you
had a chiral molecule but let's take its
mirror image let's take its mirror
imagine to take a smart image let me
clear out some real estate over here so
let me clear out this
let me clear it out so what's the mirror
image going to look like
so we have let me draw first the mirror
let me first draw the mirror so the
mirror image you're going to have a
fluorine over there then you're going to
bond to a
carbon which is also bonded to a
hydrogen and that's going to bond to a
ch2 that's going to bond to a ch that's
the mirror image of that which bonds to
a fluorine that's the mirror image of
that and then you go down this is the
mirror image of ch2 here
this is the mirror image of this and you
connect them
now these are mirror images of each
other but they are also the exact same
molecule i could just literally move
this guy over to the right and it would
be superimposed they are exactly the
same so even though we have two chiral
atoms two chiral carbons the molecule as
a whole is not chiral
so it's not chiral it is a non
it is a non-chiral
molecule